vous dites que la la france en fait
j'arrive plus à me relire en gros laisse
échapper dans les classes populaires des
gens très intelligents qui ne sont plus
repéré par le système est au contraire
sélectionne des crétins
de la france et c'est c'est eh ben on se
rentre à la mécanique générale
voilà que l'euro a tout bloqué c'est à
dire la mécanique économique est bloquée
y arriver ok on va expliquer pourquoi
d'après vous c'est parce qu'on a plus de
politique économique autonome donc la
france ne peut plus prendre de décisions
ans vit dans une sorte de zone marque
avec une monnaie étrangère qui n'est pas
adaptée à l'économie française
le livre n'est pas là-dessus générera
veille et là dessus j'ai produit un
livre là-dessus j'ai dû compétences
d'économiste si nécessaire mais dans le
cas de ce livre je rappelle simplement
que mon opinion qui est pas du tout
celle de l'assaut des françaises est
celle de tout le monde à l'extérieur a
sauté française les économistes
américains allemands suédois
je suis pas un original sur ces
questions b ce qui vous vient à penser
que ça produit une société bloquée une
société alors dans pendant les trente
glorieuses et après la sortie française
a été vraiment méritocratique c'est à
dire que le le système scolaire se
développait le secondaire le supérieur
alors mal puisqu'il y avait de plus en
plus de places à pourvoir oui c'est ça
mais alors c'est vrai que les enfants de
bourgeois reste est favorisée et se
reproduisait au sens de bourdieu
mais en fait il y avait de la place pour
d'autres est en fait le système a pour
ainsi dire pomper les individus
scolairement doué est probablement assez
intelligente des milieux populaires et
donc les avis des les milieux populaires
de saint nazaire et assure elle que les
gens qui étaient en fait avant les
cadres du parti communiste 1 par exemple
les ouvriers qualifiés super futé qui
était secrétaire de cellules du pc des
choses comme ça et donc là le bond
populaire a été désarmé
intellectuellement mais là maintenant
alors d'un côté on pourrait dire à cet
affreux maintenant il n'y a plus de
mobilité scolaire à 100 dans tout est
bloqué les enfants de cadres sup à coups
de petits cours supplémentaires ou des
tout simplement achetés dans des boîtes
privées
arrivent à se reproduire et puis les
gens d'en bas n'y arrive plus c'est vrai
que selon l'idéal méritocratique ça
n'est pas juste et je dirais d'un point
de vue révolutionnaires ou des points de
vue d'une justice à plus long terme
ça veut dire que les couches inférieures
à faire aux ressources techniques la
population sont en cours de réflexion
parce que les jets dire elles se
remplissent de chant intelligent et
alors comme le système scolaire
maintenant favorise universitaire
favorise la production de crétins
diplômés et donc on pourrait dire ce que
je dit si je résume c'est bon les gens
intelligents s'accumulant bar la
structure sociale et les crétins le taux
de crétins du diplôme et s'accumule
euros avec le lieu
le point nodal de concentration du
crétin diplômés le type dont on s'assure
qu'il n'a rien compris à la vie du monde
avant de le recruter
léna et au bout du compte non si vous
fait rentrer les gens à l'ena c'est une
condition d'entrée à l'ena c'est de
croire que l'euro marche
et comme il ne marche pas en fait de ne
sélectionner que les mecs qui ont rien
compris au monde actuel c'est
extraordinaire et au bout du bout vous
avez des crétins diplômés qui prennent
des décisions sur des taxes complètement
aberrante
aveuglé par des chiffres faux de l'insee
sur le niveau de vie qui provoque le
soulèvement des gilets jaunes et ensuite
on a cet affrontement titanesque de
leader gilet jaune super futé super
rapide dans l'auto organisation se
retrouve en face à des démunis des
premiers ministres les présidents de la
république est directement au cabinet
passé par l'ena et envers des kilos
comprennent rien donc le modèle est
vraiment opératoire
[Musique]